congrats on the film this is just really
fun to watch and you kicked
ass in this thanks i mean
that that was part of what i really
loved about the script is that it was
fun
it didn't take itself too seriously or
anything you know it was just
fun action movie just forget about
everything that's happening now even if
it's just for an hour and a half
you know no completely agree and because
there's so many more questions i want to
ask you but speaking of this time period
what has life been like for you your
wife and your kids during this time in
isolation
um i i almost feel bad saying that
we didn't realize it but we had kind of
set up our life
that the pandemic hasn't really affected
us
until you know you go to the grocery
store
and things like that but our nanny is a
preschool teacher
so she's continued to homeschool the
girls
with one-on-one teaching so
that would have been the big thing um
but they haven't
had to miss a step so you know
we have a generator we have a freezer we
have a gym so
we we just really hunkered down
and um and if you have to look for
positives
in anything and with this uh we've had
so much time with the girls
just to be able to you know especially
they're four and six so they're just
real their vocabulary is just bursting
through the roof and
um and they're creating and singing
and just randomly dancing and painting
like handmade ukuleles that they're
trying to take
it's just it's been in that regard a lot
of fun
yeah it sounds like you've had some
really nice family quality time then
that's amazing
okay so talk to me about your wwe
training and how much that came
in handy when it comes to this film and
the role you played uh well
so generally any role that i end up
taking i know at some point
physicality is going to be involved
because having been a wrestler for 28
years now
good lord uh it
when i say it like that um it's part of
it's my wheelhouse right so i always
assume
when i get a script there's going to be
some fight scenes or some kind of action
scenes
uh and i think any director
realizes pretty quickly i'm like a kid
in a candy store at that point i'm like
oh
oh okay all right well let's try this
and
so i sit down with the stunt
coordinators and they love it because
they don't come up with it all or they
can just show me once and it's like okay
we got it
and then we run through it um
and and that's always been something
i've really like enjoyed when the stunt
coordinators go dude this is
this is a day off for us i'm like okay
good that's that's the mission
um this uh with money plane i only had
one fight scene
but it was a fight scene in a cockpit
with
uh this guy casey hendershot who's six
six
so you get me who's six four he's six
six in a cockpit and it was like two
gorillas
trying to like so we added those beats
into the fight scene i go to swing a
punch but i hit my elbow
yeah because it just to keep that kind
of tongue-in-cheek
fun aspect involved yeah no that scene
was so
much fun like it just looks so real
look it looks so great well there was
some real because casey
the first punch i threw he threw his
head back well it's all
knobs and everything back yeah so it dug
right into his head
so just blood everywhere and i'm like oh
no
just started this thing now there's
continuity now there's so
it was a thing but it was he was a great
sport and and we had a great time in
there as strange as that sounds we'd
come out of there
or crews waiting to see and we'd be
laughing and hugging and
it's so what was it like for you
uh working opposite kelsey grammer
because he's just so fun as the bad guy
in this
it i love that was okay so there's two
things
when this first came across the desk it
was the script is fun
it's tongue-in-cheek it didn't take
itself seriously and that was huge for
me because i love
the john mcclane action hero i i love
that the action hero that is completely
flawed
that it can can make fun of itself
um but then i also heard that kelsey was
attached
and here's a little back story with that
okay
my mom and i the first show that that
we ever really watched together i had
just become old enough to watch cheers
with her
so thursday nights we would watch cheers
together then we would watch frasier
together
now her favorite actor bar none no one
comes close
like no one could even hold a flame
to kelsey grammer in my mom's eyes
so fast forward a few years and my mom
was diagnosed with cancer she was going
through her chemo and we would be down
there
and she would say i just want to go home
and watch frasier i'm like right that's
what we're going to do
so fast forward a year and a half passed
after she had
finally passed away and i get cleared to
wrestle again after nine and a half
years of being forced into retirement
then i get a script with kelsey grammer
attached
and i just went all right you're up
there
somewhere pulling some strings in the
ether wherever it is
yeah this movie is happening and
so you know and i got to tell him that
um which was
and and just be able to share scenes
with a guy like that who
when you when you look at the longest
character
in the history of television over
i think it's 22 seasons and won an emmy
for the same character on three
different shows
he won an emmy for a guest spot on wings
he won an emmy for
cheers he won an emmy for frasier for
one character like that's
insane and then you did opposite and
he's got these
piercing blue eyes and then his mouth
opens and you just go oh
[Music]
oh that's an amazing story
yeah it was such a great experience it
was so much fun and he was so much fun
especially with some of his dialogue
yeah that's what i think is going to
shock people when they hear some of the
stuff that falls out of his face in this
movie
and and i did i was sitting there going
oh
yeah yeah he's not supposed to say that
yeah
were you a little nervous at all to
first meet him
uh no and
i think it's just because over the years
i've
i've been lucky enough i've met all my
heroes you know i
i met hulk hogan and i met bret hart and
i met
sylvester stallone and i met like all of
these people to teenage adam
they were i've you know kiss and all of
these people i've met over the years
i've just been
lucky because of the wrestling so uh
and i understand that we're peers so i
have to treat it that way but there's
still that little part of me that's like
this is so cool i don't want to prove
that either i don't want to lose that
because that just makes it so much more
fun
oh absolutely oh my god you had so much
fun on this movie i love these behind
the scenes stories this is amazing
okay so what was it like for you working
with denise richards because she plays
your wife in this as well
yeah uh she was great super easy i mean
it um that's i think everybody came in
with the same idea
it's just this is fun and let's just
have fun with it and it was really laid
back
and it was a beautiful day in california
and uh
um it was it was just fun you know uh
it really was and then thomas jane was a
blast oh
love him he came in and he was like i
want to smoke a pipe
all right let's do it and you hear that
you go
huh interesting but then i watch the
scene
that we we share together under these
kind of porch lights and he's smoking
the pipe and i was like oh
what a great choice it worked really
well
and also added to the campiness of the
whole movie
yeah and uh so i i mean
i i was just having a blast to be
rubbing elbows you know and i still
whether it's vikings whether it's
you know haven whether it's this i just
sometimes i sit down after a take i go
okay that just happened yeah i i was a
guy that jumped around
in spandex yet here i am doing this with
these actors so it's
mine sometimes and is that something
that you want to continue to do more
because it has been really fun watching
on tv and doing the whole movies or you
know is wwe still like your number one
love
uh so here's what's interesting um
wwe is this all-encompassing thing and
when you're in it
almost it it starts to
eat up all of your mental real estate
and i think
it has to in some regard in order to put
up with the physicality of it
um that being said i never want to stop
acting
i absolutely fell in love with it and i
want to try
and juggle both of them for as long as i
can
but i also understand that the wwe
window if if being
forced to retire for nine and a half
years is enough of an illumination on
the fact that i can only do this so long
i don't know what is so
i i want to try and juggle both but i
know that when the wrestling is done
that it's it's all acting and
for a long time because i looked at it
in a very self-deprecating way like
i'm not an actor i i never wanted to be
an actor it wasn't money
and it wasn't i was wrestler when
i was forced to retire and haven called
and
uh then i flew to nova scotia and then
four seasons later
uh i i just i fell in love with it i
started taking classes i started peeling
apart
movies and performances the way i used
to do with wrestling matches
and try and understand the choices that
actors were making and really
diving deep and i realized
oh this this still fills that creative
uh void that that i'm missing if i
didn't have wrestling
and and then i was i was hooked so i i
love the process
i love the collaborative nature of it um
it's so much fun i mean you get on a set
and you sit down with some of these
performers and i just like i'm getting
paid
to to sit on the coast of ireland and
pretend to be a viking like that
school in hollywood with kelsey grammer
while we're waiting for the dog next
door to stop barking you know i mean
surreal sometimes